well let's focus on what's happening in
Ukraine itself as we saw there Russia's
been accused of sending successive waves
of drones towards seciev in the 10th
attack this month Air Raid Sirens have
sounded across the country and there
were reports of explosions but no
reported casualties well earlier today
the G7 leaders laid wreaths at the
cenotar for A-bomb victims in the
Hiroshima Peace Memorial Park that's
ahead of the start of the G7 Summit the
park is dedicated to the tens of
thousands who died in the world's first
wartime atomic bomb detonation Russia's
nuclear threats against Ukraine reports
of North Korea's missile tests and
China's expanding nuclear arsenal of all
resonated with Japan's push to make
nuclear disarmament a key part of the
summit
the military analyst former Air Marshal
Vice Air Marshal Sean Bell is here good
to see you again Sean uh we were just
talking about it there but it's been
confirmed now that uh president is going
to travel to Japan to join that G7
what's the significance of that well it
seems so let's see nobody's leaders most
recently but the G7 is the most powerful
uh democracies in the world the
wealthiest in the world and therefore
it's Unique opportunity when they're all
together for a president zlinski to make
a bit of a pitch try and get more Aid
and support from all of them it's also a
poignant that it's being held in
Hiroshima that provides a really good
backdrop for zlinski August the 6th 1945
that's the first targeted nuclear weapon
went off so the Japanese know the
horrors of war and that would be a
really powerful backdrop for zielinski
to make his appeal it's also worth
noting though that the G7 although
obviously it's only seven countries
they've invited a couple of other
countries along as guests and they
include India and Brazil why is that
interesting because neither of those
countries have been supporting slantic
up till now because of their business
tied to Russia just imagine how
difficult it will be for them in this
company with President zelinski there I
expect a bit of pressure to be brought
to bear yeah certainly an unusual uh G7
Summit uh Russia has been launching New
Waves of airstrikes over uh Ukraine last
night just tell us a little bit more
about that yeah it's been I think
there's the 10th day in succession
they've been doing this so 28 missile
attacks a mixture of missiles from
drones Ukraine claims they've shot down
three of the the missiles after the
sixth or fired and 16 of the 22 armed
drones but as you say Kiev has been
under Relentless attack for ages but
it's also interesting Russia attacked
um Cressi Rio which is over just by you
over there that's the hometown of
President zelenski I don't think that's
been attacked before a number of
explosions loads of fires several
casualties including 160 four-year-old
lady as well and let's talk about we saw
there Alex Rossi's piece from the border
of backwood what's going on at the
moment there yeah a fantastic footage I
mean they're just amazing seeing from
the front line if you remember that
we've been talking about this for over
11 months the Russians have been pushing
in if you go back to April time the
Russians crossed this back motor river
which is about here and ever since
they've been creeping inexorably forward
uh cornering the ukrainians who now hold
about two less than two square
kilometers at the west of the city now
what should Russia has been trying to do
over the last few days to do a pincer
movement and encircle them so the
Russian army have been working out on
the flanks to the North and the South
the Wagner group in working through the
middle the idea just to encircle now
unfortunately or fortunately of our
group's been relatively successful in
making incremental progress but the
Ukrainian has been pushing back at the
flanks and have been very successful at
pushing the Russian army out of the way
that's left the flanks exposed and that
means you have any precaution the boss
of the bargain group has been Furious
and has been venting his his anger at
this now Shopper and operation you get
everything to be sequenced everything to
be working well what's evident is the
Russian army and the bargain group are
actually at war with each other as well
as the ukrainians not a healthy position